Matt mccusker just blessed the comedy
world with a full hour special that he
uploaded to his YouTube channel
completely unannounced titled the speed
of light the Shaman's first full-length
stand-up special opens up with an
all-time classic rollerblading Montage
through the streets of Philadelphia this
432 Hertz special is hilarious start to
finish but what might be even funnier is
all the behind the scenes stories Matt's
been sharing about his experience
creating the special from filming the
set six times to rollerblading through
the most homeless areas in Philly dude
the first time we tried it we got we got
stuck in a red lights I was standing
outside he's like
dude right up behind me went in this
Modern Age of comedians hitting every
single podcast they can to promote their
new specials it's pretty badass that